Hey guys how's it going it's Justine and this is Jenna and today we are celebrating the 4th of July.
Whooooo!
I  got so festive, I saw these decorations at Target. I  just wanted to make sure I  pointed them out. (laughs)
Egg, and then there's the white, it's like you just put that went I
Think I should have chosen some other decoration today. We are making two different types of cupcakes
We are making some red white and blue cupcakes and some surprise cakes have you ever seen what is a surprise?
Where you make cupcakes, and we put stuff in them, and then it's like surprise well if you of course instead of wall listen
I don't know you didn't tell me anything you just an hey pour on our red shirt that looks like okay, America. Trump's
Well, we're just living in it. That's what I say about you all right? So what do we do now?
I'm a double tops opponent like there. Yeah here. Yeah, I hear you like here. Can't keep it ready. Yes
If I don't look at it, nothing bad can happen ha okay, let's crack
These maybe four egg whites so what we're doing is we're making a simple cake recipes or tada
Don't put them there you one here. So what we're doing. Here. Is you're making it simple. Cake recipe do cool white cake recipe
So you know how many times I've done this?
Enough to know why do I let her do the egg white?
I don't know why you actually did me that job because every single time I messed up
We need a ... We need a spatula please...... a spatula.
ready... catch!
hahaha Madre school
Can fill this up no, I love having a big shift
So while you're doing that I'm going to be making some of these cupcakes
Filling them half full this cupcake dispenser thing is probably the coolest thing ever
I bought it so long ago
And I never ended up using these ones are half full these are going to be our surprise cupcakes
So those are going to have comprises inside a surprise red. Nope so for the one
I'm just going to fill the bottom just a very little squirt.
You know you're going to spoon some of that into this and then I'm just airing my way
Although that's not supposed to happen
So this looks very full we want to make it like half bowl. Don't worry. Let's go got blue over here
Okay, yeah, all right sure see what I'm doing I do now
I'm just going to kind of go like this and be like a little swirl
Yeah, uh not too much tomorrow
Just like a nice little like swirl
Mm-Hmm haze like freedom yeah
That's eat the chunky. Uh that's our current political climate all right now
We're your breezes oven to 350 which I should have done probably forever and ago. Where is this surprise?
Surprise no, I got a baby's first. Oh
I'm never gonna happen that's let's clean up and prepare our icing okay. Here's our decorations
We've got our cupcake look at them nicely placed. I let them all cool off nicely so these are
America cake
Mm-Hmm. I hope you anything surprised were they surprised
So what you're going to do with this is you're gonna dig out the center
And then we're gonna put a surprise in the middle yeah, just cut out that middle laineebee
I just agree with what you're doing. I think it's wonderful. Oh slightly a finger welcome to America kids
We're testing our healthcare is it to clean my poll is it good ghost our whole breakup cycle?
Through your arms. Oh, my love is icing everywhere
portable my phone
We're gonna do ah okay, so one of those wait um
So sorry, I don't know how to do anything. We're cooking with people who know what they're doing
This is like basically cute colors cuz it's not mixed well how so fluffy oh, it's a rather is a pink
I don't think I would associate it with this video
This is oh I didn't get doesn't matter the big brand finale of a vertical subscribe little holiday crafts
Loving the tricolor scheme
Hi, there's not even a single freaking piece of red
No
Red herb feel just already oh my God. I'm gonna have my white man. Oh that looks nice else like Suicide. Oh
That was stupid. It doesn't wrinkle enough be
Writer not everyone okay, but spin
It one it money's like a lobster when it goes from blue to red. Yeah, cool
Alright guys now. It's time for these super special surprise
These are a lot of icing on here
Well the bat oh good. I woke up my skin prize surprise
Hmm wow
I've seen better marking worse. Yeah, that's not right. No. I've only seen better
It's all gone. Hope you can isis one of like Super basics
That was boring
All right, oh, oh
Well, I not will let the end of that cool
I'm gonna make it real good for you. Oh
everybody hold on
What can we got what else do we have in here?
We'll fill this up with some red balls. I forgot that this was for America. Oh
Quick all right now. We need a
icing
It's not burning. Oh everything is definitely burning may he didn't like it. He says he
He said he doesn't care
Cuz I have on do you have a one with the white and you said surprise was way more entertaining than like spooky
But I wanted it to be a suppose
we're almost done with this what happened here ah
Thanks, dude everything. Oh gosh. Why are there tears on Ya the terms of the problem I?
Think it was oh, that's my buddy. Matt. She will keep touching my body while I sing on no room my buck
Sorry, well, if it's not on it is going to be on assuming so all right? Well. I think that we did an excellent job
Let's get to a nice slow-mo look of our beautiful works of art
every word
every Copy
I could have another chance to be
again
Close three tell me
if I could have another chance
I'm so sick of eating cupcakes
I like to surprise I
Said that three hours ago, then I didn't know if the surprise was hmM try okay, thanks for watching huge
Thank you to data for all throughout this video
Happy 4th of july. I'll see you later. I
Shut my eyes trying not to be pretend am I
still your brain
Instantly, but I still hear you screaming